a tick tock trend involving school
shooting threats is prompting closures
across the country and action from law
enforcement but what's behind this
disturbing challenge we're seeing and
how is tick tock's parent company
reacting for more on this story we're
going to turn to bloomberg news reporter
nick carollo nick welcome back to quick
take start by just giving me the lowdown
on these videos what exactly are they
and when did this start happening
so we started to hear some reports
earlier this week of viral videos
cropping up on tick tock and other
social media platforms that were very
vague
messages that were warning of some sort
of school shooting or bombing activity
it generally those kinds of videos
didn't name specific places no schools
no districts
but they usually focused on december
17th and so that gave a lot of um pause
to school officials and law enforcement
officials and we're kind of starting to
see the backlash to that now
so what are those law enforcement
officials doing in response and how do
they kind of suss out the validity of
these claims versus
definitely disturbing but just just a
video that someone is making
so
generally they're looking for
specificity um we have seen some schools
close buildings out of an abundance of
caution other schools have brought in
um you know additional police presence
into their schools um but you know
generally the messages that we're
hearing from local law enforcement
officials and school officials is that
these don't appear to be credible
threats and for that reason they are
generally keeping schools open um
for like i mentioned just given the
ambiguity of a lot of these videos sure
sure and do we know why this sort of
started popping up is it a trend that
you know students are doing or is it
something more disturbing than that
we don't really know that much some
school officials have speculated that
this was a way for students to
try to cut class and it morphed into
something a little bit more sinister um
but really this is you know just the
nature of these videos and how quickly
they can spread on social media makes it
really difficult to say where it
originated or who might have started
these videos yeah of course and i wonder
too if there's any sort of uh legal
ramifications in this for the students
who've made these videos could they
get into any sort of legal trouble
i don't know for sure but i know that
schools have really gone above and
beyond trying to you know suss out where
these are coming from um
it's probably a big question for school
officials and lawmakers yeah and i
should mention in terms of the federal
response uh tick tock said that they are
working with law enforcement to look
into warnings about potential violence
at these schools i am curious what that
tells you about kind of where tic toc
sees their role coming in here and
specifically bike dance the parent
company of tick tock do they see
themselves as kind of
needing to cooperate a little bit more
than say other nameless social media
platforms might if they were in the same
situation
that's a good question you know we have
seen statements so far from tick tock as
well as
some federal law enforcement agencies
like the department of homeland security
as well as the fbi generally they have
been pretty
plain statements they're just urging
anybody with any information to come
forward and that they're
um
so far are not aware of any really
serious credible threats to schools
it's a really good question you know tic
toc is concerned with this kind of
trend that you know allegedly originated
on its platform they want to get to the
source of where these come from and it's
it's a big question not just for tick
tock but for snapchat where some of
these videos have also been seen
sure and also i know that in your
reporting one of your sources talked
about how
it's not just this challenge there's
a history of problematic content on
these platforms what what are you
hearing in your reporting about kind of
the potential normality of things like
this as scary as that might sound yeah i
mean a couple people put out statements
saying that this is not the first time
that a trend has kind of interfered with
school's ability to just educate
students in a safe way there was a trend
i think recently where students were
being challenged to slap their teachers
and it really just i mean that one is
obviously a little bit different from
this but
it does kind of bring into
um question
what is the social media's platform to
like police these kinds of trends when
they do interfere with school activities
yeah and it's also just interesting to
me the timing of this because it's right
before the holidays and we've been
reporting all week on the university
level colleges closing because of covid
so
these schools are just dealing with a
lot right now and you're reporting have
you spoken with any school officials
who've given you any insight as to how
they're thinking through their strategy
for when to
bring students into school versus keep
them at home and how much these tick
tock videos kind of play a role in that
decision
in my mind these are kind of two
separate issues the covet and the the
social media challenge but you know you
do mention in light of current events
there was um you know a legitimate
shooting that happened in michigan in
late
november and then at that same school
district uh they received some
sort of threat that was part of this
social media trend and i think that they
chose to close schools
partly because you know the impact of
our school shooting can really you know
shake up a town or a community and there
was just an abundance of caution and
parents voiced some real concern about
going back into school even though they
deemed the threat's not credible so
you're exactly right it's a really
there's a lot of stressors on schools
and schools administrators right now
and you mentioned what happened in
michigan which is of course a horrible
tragedy but specifically when i think
about that story there were so many
missteps in handling that in so many
ways that
that event could have been avoided have
you heard from any school officials
about what they've done in response to
that event and again these tick tock
videos to increase safety for students
not specifically i think it's kind of
just a whole of school effort to you
know it takes a long time to kind of
build people's trust back up and make
them feel safe and comfortable coming
back into their schools but no no
specifics on that front
all right well nick carrillo really
appreciate you giving us some context on
this really important story thank you so
much for joining us on that again that
was bloomberg news reporter nick carollo
joining us